[Music]
this personal watercraft leaps Dives and
barrel rolls with the waves but it
doesn't
capsize it's been engineered to return
to an upright position in the water and
when it comes to the fun Factor this
diving watercraft leaves other
recreational boats in its
wake to make the diving watercrafts
passenger cabin a worker sprays a gel
cat onto a form and covers it with
fiberglass a computer-driven router then
carves into marine grade plywood to
produce structural backing for the sides
of the
cockpit a worker slathers adhesive putty
onto the plywood part and applies more
adhesive to the fiberglass
cockpit he presses the plywood to the
glued areas of the cockpit and brushes
resin onto the front of the plywood
after cutting the cockpit section in two
the crew glues the parts to the inside
of the
fuselage the fabricating team applies
adhesive putty to the cone-shaped bumper
known as the sacrificial
nose they slide it onto the front of the
fuselage and then screw the bumper in
place temporarily while the adhesive
sets
another worker Sands all the fiberglass
parts of the watercraft to remove bumps
and
blemishes this piece is the engine
hatch the team bolts the aluminum
scaffold to the floor of the fuselage
this is a test fit to confirm that the
dimensions are exactly
[Music]
right as they install the scaffold they
use dummy Wing shafts to correctly
position it within the
vessel they confirm that the dimensions
are right and that the scaffold sits
Plum to the base of the
watercraft the next team inserts the
hatch frame in the rim around the
cockpit they'll bind the frame in place
later with a liquid plastic and adhesive
putty after priming the sanded surface
of the watercraft team members lower the
300 horsepower engine into the hatch
this is a dry fit to confirm everything
lines up correctly they'll eventually
remove the engine from for the final
paint and
[Music]
artwork as the dry fit continues they
connect the air tubes to the snorkle
fins that deliver air to the
[Music]
engine the engine hatch has by now also
been primed and they fit it to the
diving watercrafts main body the crew
verifies that the hatch sits flush with
the rest of the
fuselage
a worker installs the exhaust Outlet
into the hole at the rear of the
watercraft crew members slide elevator
fins into bushings at the back these
fins will control the pitch axis of the
watercraft next they install the jet
propulsion
system back to the cockpit the crew
bolts the control pedals to the floor
and run cables to the jet propulsion
unit the elevator fins and the steering
[Music]
system they reinstall the dive fin
scaffold which has been powder coated in
a yellow
color the crew connects the dive fins to
the scaffold they situate the control
panel just above the control
pedals they run a metal linkage from the
dive fins to a control
[Music]
stick they then test the control stick
and confirm it moves the dive planes
easily and
correctly bucket seats made of
lightweight carbon fiber minimize the
load for added
speed they tuck a rubber gasket into the
framework for the clear canopy that will
surround the
occupants they add a bead of sealant
where the gasket mates to the window
[Music]
frame The Vessel canopy is made of thick
aircraft grayed
acrylic it's been tinted to repel the
sun's rays and keep the temperature
cooler in the
cockpit the back canopy serves as a
hatch for accessing the
cockpit finally an artist does a custom
paint job and makes the fuselage look
Fierce with the mechanical components
reinstalled this diving watercraft is
ready to hit the
water fasten your seat belt it should be
quite a
[Music]
ride a diesel exhaust fluid or DEF tank
heater is a device which prevents diesel
exhaust fluid from freezing diesel
exhaust fluid is a solution sprayed into
the exhaust system of a vehicle with a
diesel engine to break down dangerous
polluting chemicals the tailpipe would
otherwise emit a worker programs a
robotic Bender to bend the cut to to the
required
[Music]
shape these bends are so complex that no
traditional manually operated bending
machine would be able to do them this
[Music]
accurately the heater sits right inside
the def holding tank
that's why manufacturers use stainless
steel rather than ordinary steel for
this
tubing stainless steel better resist the
corrosiveness of the DEF
[Music]
fluid at the next station a worker
inserts the bent tube into the tank
heater sensor
[Music]
unit the tube fits through openings in
the sensor unit's
header when connected by a cable to the
vehicle's computer the sensor unit
detects the level temperature and
quality of the
def next the worker puts the tubing in a
punch press Which shapes the
ends he puts those shaped ends in a
bender which curves
them another tube made the same way
siphon def from the holding tank to a
device that sprays the fluid on the
exhaust stream he installs a rubber
o-ring onto this siphon tube and applies
lubricant he installs the tube into the
header and the O-ring fits into a
notch the worker then installs a bracket
at the base of the heater riveting it to
the
[Music]
tubing the bracket holds a rubber
grommet that secures the heater in place
inside the DEF
tank further up he rivets on a second
bracket to stabilize the sensor tube
that runs down the center of the sensor
unit this prevents the tube from
rattling then he installs the return
tube which feeds any excess unsprayed
def back to the holding
tank retaining brackets apply pressure
to all the O-rings sealing the tube
connections against leaks
he flips the heater over to attach the
drain tube which is the bottom half of
the return
[Music]
tube he caps all the tubes to keep them
clean until the heater is installed in
the
[Music]
vehicle he attaches a nylon filter to
the siphon tube securing it in place
with a retaining
clip as the siphon tube draws the def
from the holding tank toward the sprayer
the filter removes contaminants such as
[Music]
sand finally this rubber grommet snaps
into the bracket at the base of the
heater The Grommet fits over a raised
bump on the tank floor holding the unit
securely in
place once connected to the vehicle's
computer the heater keeps the diesel
exhaust fluid from freezing no matter
how cold the
weather looking to get high on a new
water sport well you literally can
riding a flying water bike it attaches
with a long hose to the back of a jet
ski elevating you up to almost 40 ft
above the water where you can perform
aerial flips and Spins the jet skis
water thrust feeds three jet nozzles on
the flying water bike one propels the
bike upward the other two feed jet
control Noz that maneuver the bike after
masking the ends of the splitter a
worker sprays the completed frame jet
control nozzles and other aluminum parts
with powder coat this helps protect
against
corrosion the parts go into an oven for
up to a half hour to bake the powder
coat to a shiny
finish then workers install an aluminum
cam lock to securely fasten the fire
hose to the
coupling another worker attaches the
remaining components to the frame first
he screws in the pair of foot plates on
which the rider stands then he bolts the
bottom half of each plate to the
parallel support bars and the top half
to just ahead of the cam
[Music]
lock he mounts a padded knee rest to the
support bars it can be easily
repositioned to accommodate the rider's
height on each unpainted end of the
split
he installs an internal support
ring then a Precision Fit nylon
bushing and an external support ring
which he screws to the
[Music]
splitter the worker slides the jet
control nozzle housing over the bushing
and screws it to the internal support
ring the two control nozzles maneuver
the water bike to ascend you pull back
gradually on both of them
simultaneously to descend you push
forward on both to spin you move one
forward and one back and to do a
backflip You Yank both control nozzles
all the way
back he assembles the water bike's body
it's made of molded polyethylene with a
waterproof urethane pad to cushion the
front of the rider's body the seat is
made of the same padded
material both pad and seat attach with
plastic clips
the hollow body is completely watertight
which is why the bike
floats the final step is to mate the
body to the
frame the completed water bicycle weighs
lb once connected to a jet ski with the
fire
hose this water bike flies at a speed of
up to 20
mph by maneuvering the jet nozzles it
does has back flips multiple spins and
even Dives 20 ft
underwater solar street lights take
energy from the Sun during the day store
it and then use it to shine brightly at
night so even when the sun sets they
still provide light manufacturing begins
with the Assembly of an LED circuit
board the technician places the Optics
or lenses onto the aluminum board and
adds a silicone Foam gas for
waterproofing she secures the assembly
with a stainless steel
plate this completes the solar street
lights LED
board the next worker assembles the LED
board to the base of an aluminum heat
sink it will disperse excess heat from
the LED
board he uses several screws to secure
the LED board to the heat
sink he installs the driver which will
provide power to the LED
board once in place he connects the LED
driver to the input power
lead he now builds the decorative
housing he screws aluminum tiers
together he applies adhesive to the
upper inner Rim he inserts an optically
clear polycarbonate lens and the flange
adheres to the adhesive coated
[Music]
Rim he screws the LED heat sink assembly
to an aluminum
lid he now applies a special adhesive to
the outside rim of the light fixture
housing he presses foam tubing onto the
area once compressed by the lid it will
provide a watertight
seal with everything in an upside down
position position he lowers the assembly
over the LED heat sink and screws it to
the
lid a technician plugs the fixture into
an electrical testing
unit he confirms that all the LEDs are
Illuminating and that there are no
electrical
issues the manufacturers then transfer
the light fixture to a solar light
Factory upon arrival here a technician
does more testing to verify that its
function hasn't been compromised along
the
way the team is now ready to add the
solar power system to the LED street
light a technician programs the solar
charge and load controller another team
member places the battery that will hold
the solar charge into a vented cabinet
he connects the battery to a side clip
and ground wire he tucks insulating foam
into the sides and connects a load fuse
to the battery
wiring he plugs the controller into the
battery in addition to regulating the
battery charge and energy load it's also
a timer for the lights
operation next up is the solar array
it's a group of photovoltaic panels or
solar cells the technician sets the
solar array front side down on the
workbench he threads cable through an
aluminum back panel this cable will
serve as a ground wire he pushes a pop
rivet through a hole beside the cable
and slides the eyelet on the end of the
cable over it he then pulls the pin
through the rivet he threads wires from
the panel junction box into the opening
beside the ground
cable he tucks them into a flexible
cable at the
back he rivets the aluminum back plate
to the solar panel
array
he pulls the wires from the junction box
through holes in a
cover he solders electrical pins to the
ends of the wires and plugs them into a
single
[Music]
connector with a junction box cover
installed the solar street light system
is ready for final
testing the team assembles the street
light to a pole in the factory they
connect everything and stuff the wires
into the Po's cavity they screw the LED
light fixture to the bracket on the pole
and it's ready to
shine the Street Lamp controller senses
when it's dark and automatically
illuminates it will also detect a
well-lit environment and switch the
light off now that's Street
smarts